احتشد الالاف من الاشخاص وسط مدينه
واسطنبول تضامنا مع عمدتها المعارض اكرم
امام اوغلو ياتي هذا بعد يوم من الحكم
عليه بالسجن لمده عامين و سبعه اشهر ومنعه
من ممارسه العمل السياسي مده العقوبه
في بلدان مثل تركيا نتائج معروفه مسبقا
انه حكم قضائي غير قانوني نحن هنا وسنقاتل
حتى النهايه
في خدمه السياسه منذ فتره طويله هذا الحكم
هو احد الامثله الملموسه على ذلك لا يمكن
استخدامه جريمه الاهانه السياسيه
المؤيدين خرج امام اوغلو ومعه زعماء
المعارضه جنبا الى الجنب وهي المره الاولى
التي تلتقي فيها احزان المعارضه السته منذ
اطلاق برنامجها المشترك لمواجهه اردوغان
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه للعامل المقبل هذا
ويرجح تسريع النظر في الاستئناف من اجل
الاطاحه باي محاوله من قبل امام اوغلو
لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
[موسيقى]
غير الشرعيه
لكن لدي 16 مليون من سكان اسطنبول
وامهاء اعلانات
الحكم هذا واثاره ادانته موجه من الاستنكر
الدول